you take a picture with KD and Jason
Tatum you said you almost made this
happen I almost made that [ __ ] happen
Katie's your guy that's my guy actually
JT my guy too I actually stopped hating
KD because I went to your birthday at
his house and he was a sweetheart yeah
man and he kept complimenting my Rex
Chapman's son's Jersey he's great man
he's a great guy man he'd be getting a
bad rap cause he like to tweet and talk
[ __ ] well how did you almost make the
trade happen because within my guys and
did you convince Jason Tatum like Jalen
Brown like just look the other way on
him because you're going to get kept by
everybody you could have kept Jaylen
Brown we could have made it work how
well you're right salary cap would have
been [ __ ] up yeah but you know what I
mean like them to my guys I wanted to
see them play together that would have
been dope I mean it would that would
have been like the best way so you meet
both of them do you like
actively say yo Boston ain't that bad
I've been there so I told KD that I said
it ain't that bad not everyone's racist
not everybody they got a couple [ __ ]
too in Boston they got a couple [ __ ]
white [ __ ] dirty foot white [ __ ]
there not sure no no [ __ ] no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] they got some [ __ ] Puerto
Ricans or something yeah but you got to
go to Lawrence Massachusetts to get the
Puerto Ricans they got so bad Dominican
[ __ ] too man come on man you could go
come on man we could work boss I feel
like all the Boston [ __ ] sound like
they smoke gpcs I got a badass Spanish
[ __ ] in Boston that's telling you
badass [ __ ] Boston ain't bad I was
gonna give it a KD if he would have went
they don't all sound like they're from
[ __ ] fam you were gonna get rid of
Katie I was gonna get I was a hit man
you had my [ __ ] on the platter man do
gift do is that something you normally
do gift hoes yeah I come from a long
line of pimps of course I've gave out a
couple of gifts
nice yeah of course I would have gifted
a whole or two you know what I mean like
hey my guy's in town take care of him
yeah it's a gift you know what I'm
saying but you've got to pay some gifts
you gotta pay taxes on [ __ ] right
so that's very good yeah just tip me
um if I gifted you just give me a tip on
the back end would you say that the over
under on on on athletes not liking you
because if a girl is less or greater
than three
greater greater for sure oh yeah oh I
feel like all this should be telling
again athletes beautiful that
[ __ ] don't like me because I
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
I don't even Gotta Eat you know you know
it don't even gotta just be [ __ ] a
[ __ ] I could have just had coffee with
them like a little DM maybe I don't even
know I don't be dming hoes they'd be
dming me man I don't even be we don't
even have an Instagram there you go yeah
they find me [ __ ] I find me I like
meeting [ __ ] out in the world I'm
tired of meeting [ __ ] on Instagram I
like meeting you outside and I don't be
you know because [ __ ] be trying to
kill me because I had coffee with that
[ __ ] man I don't even be trying to [ __ ]
all the time and if you just have coffee
with a girl sometimes yeah yeah I don't
even drink coffee if it's bad she
convinced me to get into Starbucks
I'll be in that [ __ ] and I bring
my [ __ ] with me too shout out to fit
mommy shout out to the fair Mommy will
she like grab like yeah let's not get
into the Dynamics your relationship it's
obviously one that most that's for
another show most men wish they had yeah
man you guys have a great [ __ ]
arrangement I love her